[Musique]
bonsoir mercredi 3 juin bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez pour ce journal de
tv 60,18 voici les titres
la 'deadline' été fixé hier à 18h les
listes pour le second tour des
municipales ont été déposés le scrutin
est prévu le 28 juin prochain tour
d'horizon à saint quentin en yvelines et
dans les principales villes du
département
parmi les communes justement trappe ou
les trois candidatures qualifiés sont
maintenus hier un conseil municipal
étaient au programme et débuté en sous
tension avec des démissions au sein de
la majorité
enfin malgré le des compliments les
sports collectifs et de contacts restent
interdits jusqu'au 21 juin au moins de
quoi laisser beaucoup d'athlètes
orphelins de leur discipline ils tentent
malgré tout de se maintenir en forme
dans les règles ce déplacement pour
débuter cette édition brune poirson
était à maurepas cet après midi la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
de la transition écologique et solidaire
s'est rendu dans la déchetterie de la
ville et discussions autour du
fonctionnement du site et des méthodes
d'adaptation face à la crise sanitaire
et gestes barrières et distanciation
physique et depuis le 4 mai les sept
déchetteries de saint quentin en
yvelines sont rouvertes un accès se fait
sur place uniquement sur rendez vous et
les propos sont recueillis par patrick
jacques de dixmude et nicolas landry
quand on le voit et surtout quand on
voit ya à peine quelques semaines il y
avait en gros 30 % des déchetteries
seulement au plus haut pic de la crise
qui était ouverte et bien là au
contraire sans même attendre la fin du
décompte finement et bien cette
déchetterie a montré tous les acteurs
ensemble s'ils sont mis main dans la
main pour dans le respect des règles
sanitaires pouvoir rouvrir et offrir ce
service essentiel non seulement
l'environnement mais aussi à l'ensemble
des citoyens
autre déplacement ce matin celui de la
vice présidente de la région ile de
france
alexandra du blanche s'est rendu dans
une start up à montesson elle a
développé un dispositif qui permet de
respecter la distanciation physique sur
un chantier entre deux ouvriers un
projet qui a obtenu un financement de
200 mille euros dans le cadre de l'aide
pme qu'ovide mathilde et demi
pendant la crise sanitaire start up
créée en 2016 a développé un boîtier
nommé kit 42 ce dispositif permet de
mieux respecter la distanciation
physique entre les opérateurs sur un
chantier ou sur des sites industriels
quand les opérateurs donc les boîtiers
vont se rapprocher à une distance de
moins d'un mètre ou moins d'un mètre
cinquante sas est configurable aux
souhaits du client mais bien les
dispositifs vont se mettre à sonner pour
pouvoir prévenir leur porteur qu'il se
rapproche trop près de quelqu'un d'autre
pour garantir justement la distanciation
physique sociale qui est de mise
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'aide pme
qu'aux vide
dix entreprises de la région
ile-de-france ont été aidées
financièrement pour un total d'1 5
million d'euros 4 42 ans fait partie
4,42 c'est une entreprise qu'on suit
depuis 2010 9 ils ont déjà eu une aide
tp up pour les tpe d'environ 25000 euros
un petit peu moins et donc là c'est une
aide d'un peu plus de deux cent mille
euros pour les aider à industrialiser
leur production donc à produire plus et
pourvoir répondre à une demande qui
j'espère sera très importante car de 42
qui est installé dans une pépinière
d'entreprises a pour but de s'agrandir
pendant le confinement la start up a
embauché deux salariés supplémentaires
à présent elle réfléchit déjà à une
nouvelle version de kits 42 l'objectif
pour nous c'est de le déployer notamment
sur le casque parce que sur les
chantiers
on s'est rendu compte que c'était la
meilleure façon de procéder
après les retours terrain des des
compagnons sur le
sur les chantiers et on leur met poids
du dispositif est que c'est absolument
pas gênant grâce aux financements de la
région l'entreprise peut étendre ses
commandes de boîtiers et aimerait dans
un futur proche conquérir des parts de
marché autre solution penser également
dans les yvelines au premier rang c'est
le nom d'une plateforme numérique
d'entre aide scolaire pour les
collégiens et lycéens la été lancé le 29
mars dernier des élèves qui ne seront
pas tous retournés à l'école et qui sont
mises en relation directement avec des
étudiants tuteurs l'idée est de les
accompagner dans différentes disciplines
un outil développé par vous nouez
leproust bonsoir vous êtes étudiant à
sciences po bordeaux originaire de
chevreuse déjà une question toute simple
pour commencer pourquoi avoir développé
cette plateforme au premier rang voit
dans le cadre de ma formation j'étais à
l'étranger j'ai dû rentrer un petit peu
plus tôt à cause de la pandémie et au
bout d'une semaine voilà être en être
confiné chez moi je me suis aperçu de
par mes connaissances et puis mes soeurs
également avec qui j'étais que la classe
à distance était tout simplement quelque
chose qui était assez difficile à faire
et à suivre est aussi parfois pour bon
nombre d'élèves
oui c'est vrai accès en termes de
continuité pédagogique que l'on a
entendu souvent pendant cette période de
confinement avec forcément aussi le
problème de la fracture numérique qui ne
permettait pas tous les élèves de
pouvoir suivre les cours à distance est
important pour vous d'aider les élèves à
à ne pas couper le contact finalement
avec leur établissement avec la
nationalité puis avec l'éducation tout à
fait voilà et quand vous parlez plus
tard de fracture numérique
là on a sauté ce être le plus ouvert
possible et donc proposé aux tuteurs que
ça se fasse aussi bien par des
applications via ordinateur que par
l'utilisation d'un simple smartphone
alors comment vous l'avez créer cette
plateforme est ce que vous avez fait
jouer vos relations vous avez contacté
peut-être d'anciens camarades de classe
comment comment ça s'est passé
oui ça tout à fait j'ai cette idée
donc j'ai appelé de 3000 pour en parler
et puis ça s'est fait très vite un site
avec un formulaire sur lesquels élèves
et twitter peuvent s'inscrire et ensuite
voilà j'ai décroché mon téléphone j'ai
appelé les anciens de deux m'ont laissé
diffuser l'information également auprès
de mes camarades à sciences po bordeaux
et ça c'est pas bien fait assez
rapidement j'ai à dire non le lien
s'affiche en bas de l'écran pour accéder
directement à cette plateforme comment
ça fonctionne concrètement comment
bénéficier d'un tutorat en ligne bah
tout simplement si vous avez besoin ou
envie d'avoir un tuteur une tutrice vous
remplissez un petit formulaire sur
lequel vous avez d'accès sur le lien et
avec ce formulaire là nous on va
recevoir votre demande et de l'autre
côté nous avons la même plate forme avec
le même formulaire pour les tuteurs et
notre rôle c'est vrai tu vois là de
faire coordonner cette sorte de petit
match qui va être fait entre un élève et
sur twitter
c'est gratuit ce tutorat en ligne tout à
fait c'est le c'est un point très
important de notre plateforme c'est
entièrement gratuit
les étudiants sont bénévoles et voilà
l'idée c'est d'être le plus ouvert
possible et que le plus de personnes
puissent s'inscrire lors des élèves d'un
côté vous l'avez dit des tuteurs de
l'autre qui sont-ils justement ces
tuteurs et bien ce sont des étudiants
pour la plupart entrant ils sont en
première année jusqu'au quelques
doctorants également des élèves des
étudiants qui sont à la fois je suis
double in voilà qui étudient dans la fac
d'orsay la fac de 50 ha le plateau de
saclay il puis voilà 2 g par le fait que
j'étudie mois aborde beaucoup
d'étudiants de sciences po bordeaux
également on l'a dit une plateforme
lancée depuis le 29 mars après plusieurs
semaines de fonctionnement quels sont
les les principaux besoins des
collégiens des lycéens que vous avez pu
relever ce qu'il ya des choses qui vous
qui vous ont été remontés sur sur ses
besoins principalement ça va être
d'approfondir d'avoir un suivi
personnalisé auprès de notions qui
parfois sont difficilement abordable du
premier coup d'oeil du prime du premier
avis avec le professeur donc ça va
naître une pédagogie tout simplement de
répétition et de cette idée d'
accompagnement personnalisé qui
normalement au sein de l'établissement
scolaire qui ne peut plus faire
malheureusement depuis le confinement et
où le même aujourd'hui avec la reprise
de façon assez partiel est ce que les
retours sont donc elle ce qu'elle est le
premier bilan que vous pouvez dresser
sur cette plateforme en termes de bilan
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont adhéré et
que je remercie évidemment pour l'élan
de générosité qu'il ya eu on a une
quarantaine de binômes qui ont été
formés depuis le début voilà et puis
des actions de communication etc ont
fait connaître peu à peu notre notre
plateforme et nous avons été mis en lien
dernièrement avec la cité éducative de
trappes
voilà pour développer un partenariat
auprès des élèves de youri gagarine au
collège de trappes j'allais finalement
terminer cet entretien avec vous là
dessus oui les liens avec la cité
éducative de trappes qui s'intéressent à
cette plateforme ils peuvent être amenés
à ceux à se développer c'est celle 1
c'est l'une des pistes de développement
en tout cas pour votre plateforme chat
pourra l'être en effet donc c'est un
projet qui est piloté à la fois par la
préfecture
l'académie de versailles et puis
évidemment la ville de trappes et donc
voilà pour nous c'est aussi l'occasion
de s'engager dans un autre pan un petit
peu du tutorat au delà de notre simple
action et pourquoi pas à terme
effectivement s'engager sur sur le moyen
ou long terme avec ce collège mais plus
d'informations directement sur cette
plateforme en vous rendant sur la
plateforme au premier rang le lien elle
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
d'avoir été avec nous et le proust
fondateur d' au premier rang et et bravo
pour cette initiative
[Musique]
le point à présent sur la situation de
la co vide 19 dans les yvelines aux
dernières données datant d'hier mardi
des deux décès supplémentaires ont été
enregistrés dans les hôpitaux le virus a
fait 496 victime sur le territoire 570
patients étaient hospitalisés hier dans
le département qui compte huit nouvelles
hospitalisations 37 sont en réanimation
soit un cas supplémentaires en 24 heures
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire et
1906 personnes ont été guéries après un
passage à l'hôpital et j - 25 avant le
second tour des élections municipales et
je vous le disais dans les titres les
candidats avaient jusqu'à hier 18 heures
pour déposer leurs listes
tour d'horizon à saint quentin en
yvelines où sept communes sont
concernées et ce tour d'horizon c'est
avec aurélie ans à l'issue du premier
tour aux clayes-sous-bois quatre
candidats étaient susceptibles de se
maintenir pour le second tour finalement
stéphanie jamin se retirer ce sera une
triangulaire avec une seule liste de
gauche celle de nicolas u qui sera
opposé à philipp guiguen et anne-claire
frémont sur la liste de cette dernière
figure la maire sortante véronique côté
millard qui entre-temps a préféré
soutenir son premier adjoint philippe
kigen à guyancourt quatre candidats
étaient en ballotage à l'issue du
premier tour
pour ce second tour la liste d'olivier
paréja fusionne avec celle du maire
sortant françois morton les guyancourt
tôt auront donc le choix entre trois
listes françois morton rodolphe baril et
grégory pape
pas de surprise à plaisir les trois
listes arrivées en tête lors du premier
tour se maintiennent pour le scrutin du
28 juin la liste de la maire sortante
joséphine coleman berger sera opposée
aux listes de patrick jean terre et
annie joël prieur sni pour ce second
tour il n'y aura pas d'alliance attrape
ce sera une triangulaire avec la liste
du maire sortant guy malandain celle de
son ancien adjoint à lire à b enfin la
liste du conseiller municipal
d'opposition entre manas roues à la
verrière sur les quatre listes du
premier tour trois sont en lice pour le
28 juin prochain
celle de la maire sortante nelly duthu
la liste de son premier adjoint jean
yves blé et celle du conseiller
municipal d'opposition nicolas dainville
surprise en revanche à villepreux avec
une fusion de listes celle de valérie
blin arrivé en seconde position lors du
premier tour et celle de sylvie se bat
on l arrivée 4e
il y aura donc une triangulaire à
villepreux avec le maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau valérie bain et jean
baptiste à monique 3 c'est également le
nombre de listes pour le second tour à
voisins le bretonneux des listes
identique à celle du 15 mars dernier
celle de la maire sortante
alexandra rosetti celle d'olivier à
france ô et de béatrice pierrât
ce sont en tout 45 communes des yvelines
où les habitants devront retourner aux
urnes le 28 juin prochain à
mantes-la-ville pas de quadrangulaires
mais un duel à deux romains carbone dès
le lendemain du premier tour avait fait
savoir qu'il se retirait la candidate de
la gauche à mitis mestdagh il s'est
également retiré de la course il ya deux
jours conséquence pour le scrutin du 28
juin le maire sortant rassemblement
national cyril notre fera pas ça la
liste divers centres de samy est damée
registre un duel d'ailleurs dans lequel
s'est immiscé pierre bédier le président
du conseil départemental des yvelines
est élu dans le canton en demande a
appelé à voter pour samy damerdji dans
un communiqué pour mettre fin je cite à
la paralysie l'isolement-- à l'égarement
de la commune au bureau ce sera une
triangulaire entre les trois candidats
arrivés en tête lors du premier tour le
maire sortant françois garay fera face
au candidat divers droite hervé riou et
à la candidate cet hiver gauche agnès
étendard enfin à rambouillet c'est une
triangulaire également la candidate
divers droite issu de la majorité
sortante véronique matignon arrivé en
tête le 15 mars dernier sera opposé à la
liste de l'écologiste david jutier et à
la liste lrm de judo schmitz communes
concernées par le second tour de ces
municipales trappe ou vous l'entendiez
trois candidats se maintiennent le maire
sortant guy malandain fera face à l'élu
d'opposition othman neuf trous et à ali
rabais en ballottage favorable qui a
siégé dans sa majorité pendant six ans
c'est donc dans un contexte particulier
que se dérouler ce mardi le conseil
municipal de la ville
une séance à huis clos en raison de la
crise sanitaire est quelque peu
mouvementée manon marathon
al'approche du second tour des élections
municipales c'est un conseil à huis clos
qui a débuté sous tension à trappes
l'ordre du jour prévoyait et trois
délibérations pour retirer les
délégations de plusieurs élus de la
majorité
parmi eux ali rabais en tête après le
premier tour
candidat face au maire sortant guy
malandain en troisième position
l'adjoint a préféré remettre sa
démission avant la tenue du vote le
concernant nous étions prêts
collectivement à travailler autour du
maire pour élaborer un certain nombre de
mesures pour travailler ensemble à la
sortie de la crise au lieu de cela le
maire a décidé d'inscrire à l'ordre du
jour le retrait de délégation et donc le
règlement de compte avec un certain
nombre d'élus qui ont choisi de ne pas
soutenir sa cinquième candidature que
nous avons estimé à bien des égards
comme la candidature de trop et donc
nous avons décidé de ne pas participer à
cela de démissionner collectivement
qu'on peut pas faire campagne contre une
personne et une équipe et puis être
délayé de cette personne et de ses
tripes ce problème de problèmes de choix
d'honnêteté intellectuelle
cet élu de la majorité en tout ont
quitté le conseil municipal du côté de
l'opposition othman nassr ou arrivé en
deuxième place au premier tour a bien
assisté à l'ensemble de la séance malgré
une prise de parole critique sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire attrape
démissionner comme cela à la dernière
minute n'a aucun sens alors qu'il a
approuvé 100 % des décisions pendant six
années je crois que le fait que c était
retransmis aujourd'hui sur internet
on a envie d'être dans la politique
spectacle nous nous sommes restés nous
n'avons pas quitté le conseil municipal
parce qu'ils avaient des dossiers
importants à voter pendant quatre heures
maintien du taux de la fiscalité locale
pour 2020 approbation de la convention
de la cité éducative ont été votés
pendant cette séance le conseil a
également décidé de renommer le centre
de santé municipal en hommage docteur
jacques fribourg médecins urgentistes de
l'hôpital privé de trappes décédé du
coronavirus trois sous dr
pas risquer sa vie pour sauver d'autres
vies
voilà et et pour nous vu le travail fait
par l'hôpital et le travail que nous
nous faisons un collaboration
partenariat que nous avons avec
l'hôpital
et puis le témoignage maîtrise mais
réelle de de ce monsieur c'est c'est
bien c'est bien qu'on n'ait sa mémoire
lakovic 19 à bouleverser également la
vie économique le conseil a annulé les
loyers pour les résidents de la
pépinière chrysalide pour les mois
d'avril et mai au chapitre culture et
patrimoine les conditions de la
réouverture sont connus le château de
versailles accueillera de nouveau ses
visiteurs à partir de samedi prochain le
site a dévoilé aujourd'hui dans un
communiqué
le dispositif pour ce faire le château
les jardins le parc le domaine de
trianon et le domaine de marly seront
accessibles les grandes eaux musicales
elles joueront dès le premier jour de la
réouverture pour garantir la
distanciation physique une billetterie
avec réservation horaires obligatoire et
mis en place l'objectif est de réguler
les flux à l'intérieur du musée port du
masque obligatoire à partir de 11 ans
sens de circulation unique lavage des
mains obligatoire à l'entrée
l achat des billets en ligne est
fortement recommandée et puis malgré le
déconfinement amorcée depuis le 11 mai
plusieurs sports sont encore à l'arrêt
jusqu'au 21 juin les disciplines
collectives et de contacts restent
interdites
c'est notamment le cas de la boxe du
football américain ou encore du basket
mais les pratiquants trouve des
solutions tout de même pour continuer à
s'entraîner le reportage de michael et
demi d'euros
[Musique]
en cette journée ensoleillée cinq
footballeurs américains des templiers
d'elancourt ont ressorti leurs ballons
depuis le déconfinement privé de séance
d'entraînement en club à cause du coc
u19 ces sportifs viennent volontairement
chaque semaine cinq matinées sur sept
dans ce parc de guyancourt objectif
s'entretenir physiquement et surtout
pouvoir regoûter à leur sport bien sûr
c'est important ça nous a manqué pendant
trois mois on et focus avec nos
objectifs et on revient toujours
s'entraîner avec lydie dans le tête de
jeu l'année prochaine on va dire le foot
us d avis que j'ai recueillis autour de
moi c'est comme une drogue pour tout le
monde franchement
et même si on aime tous les sports à peu
près le foot le basket le foot us on en
a besoin
les joueurs de football américain ne
sont pas les seuls à être en manque de
sport en ce moment les basketteurs
trappistes bamba cei s'entraîne seul sur
les terrains de sa ville en extérieur le
joueur essentiel entente le chesnay
versailles n'a plus joué depuis le mois
de mars
mais il veut garder la forme à 40 1 en
vue de la saison prochaine en nationale
3 ça va être technique individuelle donc
on tire des posteurs et tout ça donc on
aura faire tout doucement
s'il ya du monde noir on peut faire je
peux faire d un contrat de groupe ii est
aussi plus shooter chute est beaucoup
plus contraignant les entraînements de
boxe se passe actuellement en extérieur
la dizaine de boxeurs de la team
farrugia et l'encours se réunissent
régulièrement pour pratiquer leur
passion respectant les gestes barrière
des combats sont notamment interdits les
sportifs amateurs et professionnels du
club sont ce jour là sur une piste
d'athlétisme à trappes
chacun doit être presque à l'autre côté
du stade pour s'entraîner bon j'exagère
un petit peu mais c'est à peu près ce à
quoi ses courses abdos pompes
la musculation spécifique voilà ça reste
soft princesse ça fait plus aux
entraînements de vacances qu'autre chose
moi tous ces athlètes espère désormais
un retour à la normale rapide le
gouvernement a annoncé la réouverture
des salles de sport gymnase et piscine
pour le 22 juin prochain dans les
yvelines qu'il faudra sûrement patienter
tout l'été pour la reprise dans les
clubs locaux
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité très belle soirée à tous
sur tv 78
[Musique]